youtube rewind did an oopsy pewdiepie
i mean pewdiepie did an oopsy soldier
boy
date an oopsy and the forbes did an
oopsy i'm oopsie-doopsy
oopsy-doopsy-doopsy
time
[Music]
welcome to pew news the most diverse
news source of all time
we have literally everyone working here
people are campaigning to get pewdiepie
more subscribers because
hey he needs to destroy t series b
because he's the most epic
youtuber or c because straight men have
too much time on their hand
because straight men have too much time
on their hands
i'm not saying people shouldn't be
straight i just don't need their culture
shoved in my face all the time
straight people be like subscribe to
pewdiepie everybody
i don't even know if this is a legit
website
you know if people campaigning for
pewdiepie to get more subscribers have
too much time on their hand
what the frick do people that complain
about it have huh
destroyed with facts and logic literally
what do straight nerds
spend their money on question mark oh
this side is legit
oh it's legitimate right to be fair the
whole subscribe to pewdiepie thing
has just become a meme it's getting out
of control i'll admit to that at least i
had one of the straight i mean
pewdiepie had one of the strangest days
i can only imagine
when not only jordan peterson hey jordan
what are you doing right now
i'm subscribing to pewdiepie but also
logan paul
urges people to subscribe to pewdiepie i
mean what the frick is going on
here guys hello gang i have put a
trackable link
in the description of this video that
when clicked
will automatically subscribe you to
pewdiepie's channel so logan paul said
that day he will donate to charity of
his choice
for every person that clicks his link to
that redirects to subscribe to
pewdiepie i'm desperate oh that's what
god did
i mean logan wanted me to wear his merch
as a as an exchange for this
you must wear this piece of maverick
merch in one of your upcoming videos
currently being delivered to you
via courtier okay first of all i didn't
give logan my address because i i didn't
know what the hell he wanted
i gave him the address of a swedish
crafting shop but
i'll i'll keep the promise that i never
made it i guess
but then again you look at the graph and
you see the sub gap and i mean it's not
even nearly as
impactful as the markiplier one see here
is when
markiplier did the shout out and here's
when
did is but i think there's one thing we
can learn from all of this which is of
course
subscribe to pewdiepie it's not that
hard
it's one click away what the frick are
you doing
to be honest i am a bit overwhelmed by
the whole thing the sub gap is still
reducing my twitter is just over blown
with
subscribe to pewdiepie all these
companies getting into it
pornhub subscribe to pewdiepie playing
[ __ ] lasagna in a mall until someone
asked me to stop in order to save
pewdiepie and there's more events going
on from fans and other youtubers than i
could possibly
keep up with grade calculator don't want
to study
subscribe to pewdiepie i want people
hacking gta to say subscribe
to people but my my favorite one which
of course is
pewdiepie supporters call on prime
minister theresa may
to help him defeat t-series yes that's
right everybody that's an actual
headline
as much as i'm absolutely humbled and so
happy about all the support
i i do feel really weird about it and i
wanted to do a
shout out to a bunch of smaller creators
as well or that maybe don't have
as much subscribers just because there's
a lot of great channels on youtube
that actually deserve subscribers i know
subscribe to pewdiepie is a meme and all
and i appreciate it but
i made a list and it's in the
description and i'll go through it at
the end of this video
of channels that i watch that i think
deserves more subscribers or
that i just enjoy watching next news
youtube rewind you've probably seen this
train wreck of a video already
did anyone actually like the video for
youtube
you know what no no stop the reason i'm
bringing up user rewind again is because
it's made history that's right as the
fastest
most disliked video of all
time on wikipedia youtube rewind became
the fastest video to climb this list
gaining over 4 million dislikes in less
than 48
hours and it's currently the second most
disliked video
on youtube youtube beat my own video of
can this video get 1 million dislikes i
mean pewdiepie's video
it needs 9.7 to become
the most disliked video on youtube which
is baby
by justin bieber that's crazy i didn't
think it out
that bad but as always passing the
question on to you guys
what do you think about it i mean i
didn't even have to critique the video
it just speaks from itself you just
watch it and it's just a cringe fest
a celebrity in rewind a twitch streamer
and rewind
a youtuber who hasn't posted a video in
nine months
and i don't want to be all salty the
fact that i wasn't in rewind
i kind of get it i guess the thing is i
thought last year was equally bad
but it seems like this year i guess it's
the year when
people really open their eyes to how
how much youtube has really changed in
their approach to
its creators next news
soldier boy exciting news from soulja
boy
finally soldier game console and
handheld that's right they're here game
revolution
made an article about it soulja boy
tweeting wow my console is selling
fast dreams do come true thank you
fans this is only the start well he
wasn't kidding it really was only the
start
now the handheld version has over 3000
games in it and
if you question its legality or why this
exists then
what the freak you're just a hater this
thing has game boy advance games and all
kinds of stuff
dude it's got an rca output haven't seen
those in a year
thank you soldier boy for bringing that
back hdmi
i don't think so now if you cannot just
like myself
have enough of soldier soldier boys
product
he of course has the soldier watch if
you're a true soldier part of the
soldier army
but you wouldn't just have the handheld
you wouldn't just have the console you
wouldn't just have the soldier watch
you would also have the soldier phone
that's right
or you would not even that you're not a
true soldier fan
unless you have the soldier gift card
[Music]
soju boy was very pleased with their
reaction about his game console
saying that to the first person that
purchased my console
you just brought tears to my eyes tears
of joy thank you
so much for your support i promise to
continue my tech company
and evolve it in the gaming world i'm
just a kid
with a dream after the release of soulja
boy
game console as as you probably would
have guessed already
nintendo stock completely plummeted xbox
microsoft stock practically non-existent
playstation stock committed seppuku
if it wasn't obvious these are
practically just chinese knockoff
products that you can buy already
for also a much lower price on different
websites
the console it looks identical and it
sells for 30 dollars but
if you want the soja boy version then
it's 199.
soja boy is just an artist that i truly
respect and truly admire for his
integrity
his innovation but most importantly his
rap game of course
you've probably heard of this website
called cameo where you can pay
uh b or c list celebrities to get a
shout out
now i did it and nine out of ten said no
i was gonna do a video where i make fun
of all these desperate youtubers for
accepting this brand deal but surprise
surprise no one wanted to do it
except one man one man was greedy enough
for the challenge life spot it's your
boy soldier where shout out to my man
felix man
you already know what it is how's it
going bros my name is
pewdiepie you all yo
thank you sojour boy very cool
next news when fans go too far
pewdiepie stands stuns and youtube's
next big problem now i mentioned this
before
i i think in last y because this is the
article
by the telegraph attacking me and my
fans for being problematic it came out
this exact same day that we raised 250
for uh cry the indian charity for to
prevent child labor
i usually ignore this kind of stuff but
i just thought it was
crazy how they posted this at the same
time but this article you have to pay to
read it
and i i never bothered to pay for it but
some of you guys
sent me a screenshot of it and it's it's
hilarious
because it talked about the subscribe to
pewdiepie hack
and how uh the hacker as they mention it
hacker giraffe
is rumored to be only nine years old
journalism everybody good job good job
everybody
you did it it seems so many people fall
for the nine-year-old meme i love it so
good
anyway that's all i had to say next me
forbes made uh
their yearly top 10 list of the most
paid youtubers or gamers or whatever
they do
uh they always reach out and to ask if
the numbers are correct i don't think
because it's none of your business
forbes but let's have a
look at it logan paul is number 10
pewdiepie was number
nine jacksepticeye beat me to it
vanished gaming marketable
i think dantdm was the highest paid last
year if i remember correctly
now a lot of people seem to take these
as facts it's just pure speculation like
forbes has no idea
so there's really no reason to even take
this seriously but they did rank ryan
toy's review
number one a literal not as
nine-year-old seven-year-old
when he gets nine oh boy
things are going to be different around
here not everyone was too pleased about
this uh
list and the main reason i'm bringing
this up is because
my newly favored youtuber lily sings had
some interesting things to say about it
two years ago it was almost even between
male and female
last year it was just me and this year
there are no females at
all so she was on the list last year but
now she
there's no female on the listies this
year something i predicted in my
instagram caption last year
i'm concerned the digital space is going
to repeat the mistakes of ancient
industries
hope i'm wrong you know
maybe this is a crazy idea but maybe you
should uh
maybe you should plan a campaign or
something like that to increase your
revenue
something about uh mental health and
then just come back and sell a bunch of
merch afterwards
that would be a great idea maybe that
will help you earn more revenue hey guys
i work too much i need a break buy my
hustle merch
imagine being actually mad about the
fact that a seven year old
and maybe is the most paid youtuber
i think what's interesting about this
whole thing is it's saying
that men are being paid more than women
on in the youtube space which is
obviously just ridiculous you don't get
paid more or less based on your gender
adsense pays the same way if people want
to subscribe to you
they generally do it because they enjoy
your videos not because of your gender
that's just ridiculous but if you start
complaining about this you literally
just sound like a crybaby and an idiot
which you are lilly things
just in case you weren't sure that was
it for pianos
hope you guys enjoyed this video we
reached 75 million subscribers
it's so ridiculous i have a video
waiting to go
up that we work day and night to make
happen
at the time when t-series gonna pass
that i can't upload now
because you guys keep subscribing stop
subscribing and in fact uh subscribe
instead
to of all these channels that i'm about
to list now the video's over but if you
want to
keep watching you can subscribe to james
lee he does incredibly cool
videos uh he's an animator
check it out it definitely deserves more
subscribers we have
nikki jakey who he has a considerable
amount of following but he's just a
great channel
still underrated he does uh video game
essays and
talk about stuff that's right that's the
best explanation i can do
on the fly check them out subscribe
willian osman great channel
he's an inventor and he does all these
crazy
builds he had a laser cut vin diesel ham
and cheese sandwich all right here's an
actually smaller channel called alsboyd
she does political and social
videos talking about these interesting
topics she does in a very engaging
and interesting way i really enjoy
watching her great channel
then we have a a panda who made a top 10
reasons why you should sub to pewdiepie
he expected some payment for this but
instead you get a shout out so stop
asking me for money all right
next up we have a trip visuals
i don't know i just like this i just
like it okay he does really sick
animation
edits with cool soundcloud rap music in
the background
bacon which i've shouted out before he
does the funniest uh
oblivion meme definitely check him out
check out bacon
he also last time i shouted me out he
told me about the left bros who's doing
an oblivion playthrough right now small
channel they're really funny guys
he's the one that did the original uh
oblivion parody videos that i referenced
so many times in my videos they're so
funny and speaking of oblivion check out
also will burger we also have beppies
he's a a great meme channel definitely
subscribe to babies he's helped me out
with a couple meme reviews as well so i
really appreciate it we also have diesel
patches
a great channel that calls out a bunch
of both on youtube if you like that kind
of stuff check them out
we have dp023
this is hilarious channel i i i watched
him in
yesterday's videos your life you lose so
funny check them out
dylan loki or lock he did a remix for
[ __ ] lasagna it's absolutely amazing
i'm gonna re-upload it on my
uh channel in a couple days but he's
super underrated guys super talented
i don't know what to call him mixer
editor i don't know
next up we have eight thoughts uh he's
another channel that calls people out
generally a bunch of [ __ ]
really entertaining i enjoy watching his
videos i gotta give a shout out to my
man
evan edits he did this amazing edit of
uh
the pewdiepie anime opening just like
talented memes
a good old memester everybody actually i
don't know if i'm yeah i should chat
about because he's done so many great
ones for me i also got to give a shout
out to
evan kung he's kind of like the live
sketch version of grande and dolan
[Music]
i hope he doesn't mind that description
i gotta give a shout out to joe jenkins
he did this hilarious video where he
played [ __ ] lasagna on actual lasagna
also of course camilla's sushi kill
another amazing meme account they
helped us very frequently he or she i
don't know nihonium as well
of course another great meme account you
should follow
memeology101 a great channel is well
found through betterhelp stuff
uh uploads very frequently always on top
of topics really enjoy this channel
i gotta give a shout to simon says he
did this video
uh called thank you pewdiepie and he
basically explained in hindi
uh my kind of humor and why you
shouldn't be offended by it i thought
it was really cool he'd draw examples of
how the [ __ ] lasagna memes and
how you india you lose is a reference to
your life you lose and you're slightly
you lose which i made fun of before and
just a really funny guy like uh i i
think it's really cool what he's doing
i appreciate it we have sarah zedd who
does
reviews and video essays very
entertaining check her out
great exact great description we also
have surreal entertainment already gave
him a shout out it's such a funny
channel
swedish boy shout out to my swedish boys
oh no
all my children died i recently
discovered this channel but it's god
damn amazing
the probe it's just
it's dark souls animation
but they're so goddamn good we also have
wavy web surf
sub tier pewdiepie check them out very
good my favorite channel though
sillier sis i mean this channel is an
absolute treat
he's the lily sings of russia there's uh
daily vlogs
we also have nyarons i don't know how to
say it
if you want to listen to some music that
will instantly put you in a better mood
check out the rns why don't we just end
it there
thank you for 75 million subscribers
i'm gonna link all these channels in
description check them out why not let's
find some new channels
and uh that's it for me for now goodbye
everybody